okay let's make the call let's make the
call okay if uh do you need the
connection there so this is who can you
tell us yes so this is a good friend of
mine his name is ramon ponce de leon and
and i was incorrect he's not the head of
the teamsters union it's it's the crane
operators union and i'll let him clarify
that but great guy lives in southern
california has been in this union for a
very long time he's the president he has
everybody underneath them and knows
everything that's going on he can answer
all these questions and tell us a
firsthand account of what's going on
with the creation
what the payback is going to be for the
24 7 90 day biden sprint yeah and he i
talked to him for a while yesterday i
mean they're already working their butts
off i mean there's really maybe two or
three hours that the ports aren't active
right now it's from 3am to 6am other
than that they are you know unloading
these things constantly
and i also asked him about you know how
now long beach the mayor of long beach
said you can now stack crates six high
as opposed to one or two so that was
going to alleviate some of the space of
these things going out into the
warehouses all over once the once the
the ships were unloaded and he didn't
think that was a great idea so
here's here's the thing won't that
complicate things for the crane
operators this this is what i think
about with this is okay you're gonna
find them a hundred dollars per
container and incrementally increase it
a hundred dollars per day
doesn't that even piss off people to not
want to come back and do business with
you that's what i'm talking about that's
what i'm talking about
the next time the ship sails it's headed
for the panama canal it's headed for
houston it's headed for miami that's
what i'm trying to say that this is
going to leave a really bad taste
and and even though it's the way things
are done you go shanghai to long beach
you go shanghai to los angeles even
though that's the way it's always been
done if you start to find people to
kingdom come
they're going to divert okay they're
going to divert the truth on the line
here is it up
i'm going to have to turn the podcast
off right hey hey ramon
hey
yes thanks so much ramona and i know
this is a scramble and i apologize for
it
well that's why we have you on the phone
i think hey ramon say hi to patrick bet
david kai is here as well as well as
danielle
good morning hello patrick ramon how are
you raise the audio a little bit kai
yes ramon so so educate us on if you
don't mind the audience doesn't know
your background if you can take a quick
second and tell us your background what
you do there and then uh what's really
going on in l.a by the way you may want
to take that off because there's a lot
of static noise right now just give me
the phone
sure you're driving ramon
oh
whose phone is this buddy
did we lose him
i think he's listening to the podcast
too so we'll call him yeah i think we
lost him so he's the president well he
runs the union he has 7000 he runs the
crane operators and i don't want to you
know say this incorrectly and we'll let
him clarify but he is the president of
the union he
the cranes the trucks everybody that's
coming in thousands yes seven thousand
employees so there isn't a more
qualified person to tell us what's going
on
uh uh agreed and this is cr again
to me at least this is critical because
the the the long shore union contract's
coming up on june 30th and i just
i i think they're out for a big huge
pound of flesh
okay so ramon if you're listening on the
podcast we're coming right back to you
here in a second david did you get it or
no
just a phone call guys i you put it on
phone call i put them on speaker
you know how you go to calls
and then just enter that the numbers
that we have it's 10 digits
there you go david
i know he had it enough hello can you
hear us now
can you hear us
yes
fantastic
okay excellent we're glad you did that
so so so tell us tell the audience a
little bit about your background and
what the current conditions are at the
port
okay uh my background is uh
i'm a third generation longshoremen we
are called longshoremen because back in
the day they used to ask for labor they
would say along the shore
when though we became long-term
uh where the ilw
and
um i represent uh local 13 which is the
the mostly the labor
of uh the ports of l.a and long beach
collectively probably about 8 000
members close to 8
uh with a casual workforce they'll be
included would include another four
thousand
so about four thousand yeah
that's that's who uh works under the
contract document that
that i enforced as
the
president for local 13.
so what is life like right now
ramon what is life like right now for
folks who are working there what is the
day-to-day looking like how how there's
a different story between what the media
is saying you're in it tell us is it
worse is it same is it better what is it
like
well first of all since covet we have
not stopped no one even looked at us we
kept working we had 20 active members
die as a result of covet uh some would
uh report to work be sick and three days
later they passed it it was that quick
a lot of phone calls to a lot of
families was really discouraging but uh
since then we've never stopped as a
matter of fact we've broken records uh
volume records throughout the year we're
continuing to break records
our people are working
double shifts for the most part because
of the volume
we are we have a process of registration
a list that has already been
uh
attained by the parties back in the
early
2015
and we're still going through that list
to continue to hire through our list
we'll probably have a new list when the
next contract comes around now i just
want to say something
the automated terminals are are just uh
they're predicated on density
which you have premium land on the ports
and the congestion has exposed that
if you continue to automate what's going
to happen
is you're gonna use more trucks if
you've been to southern california
there's no more room for trucks
we've been advocating rail
now we can load a rail with our top pick
drivers it's like a big forklift that
picks the container up on the top side
we can move between 50 and 60 containers
an hour and have a train of 300 moves
with two gangs we call them gangs two
units and in five hours we have a train
of 300 containers on the road so we need
to be pushing for rail infrastructure
through the ports we are not a storage
facility we should be a throughput
facility automation is a storage
if you can stack if you go to the court
and you go see it so
i'm just trying to uh bring everybody to
line here sure
our stacks are probably four high okay
now
the stock speed is a little high because
our yard craze are for hot uh they could
they have to be able to go over it so if
you have to if there's six rows you have
to get the can on the bottom you have to
take the cans away guys on top get the
bottom can and then load it and then put
the cans back okay and because of the
congestion it continues to remain full
because when the vessel comes in we just
put more right back on top
so and if you automate even if it's an
automated crane with no person in it
if it goes eight or nine nine can you
imagine digging out eight or nine high
so
what what is the risk by the way if it
goes eight or nine high what is the risk
for safety if it goes eight or nine high
well
well in an automated terminal there's
nobody there okay so all you did was you
just further congested the ports
automation the farce okay
we we've already proven
we've improved in the footing we've
already moved the volumes higher than
anybody in this nation ever has in the
history of this nation this container
and it's obvious when we haven't had
containers you know back in
the 30s but
we are moving cargo faster than anyone
has ever had in any port and by the way
harbor maintenance tax
is a tax where the gulf and the east
coast
take more percentage to to build their
ports than our ports that that have that
are southern california boards with the
40
throughput for this nation
now let me back up one more step
there are 10 major carriers in the world
of all waterborne goods
of those 10 carriers we have three
alliances
it's a monopoly
okay they control the price of the
container
they control it
and guess what what recently in the last
decade they have
they have now taken control of their own
terminal operator the terminal operators
who employ us
used to be the mom and pop founded here
in the u.s
people
that
born and raised here they're still
those employees but the control is the
carrier they're all foreign owned
there's none here now and they are
recording 3.5 billion dollars a quarter
cma cgm the number three
is in that chain
the number three carry
has recorded 3.5 last quarter and 2.1
the quarter before
merc is the number one they recorded in
two different quarters back in the
pandemic during the summer of 2020 and
the first quarter of 2021
you combine those two a 4.3 and a 2.7
that's seven billion dollars of revenue
that and if you do the math on that the
average is 3.5 i'm gonna continue with
this 3.5
and none of that money goes back into
our infrastructure none of it goes back
into our economy
so
we've lost our beaches we lost our
manufacturing
all right look at detroit
and now here's the third part
they are not calling the port of oakland
there's no backlog there and you know
what oakland is terminally used for
export of agriculture
what happens if our farmers lose farm
are we going to be asking other
countries for food and what's that price
going to be and who controls the price
we are americans working for america
so so let me ask you this here so the
questions about some of these other
states that are sitting there saying hey
if you have like desantis says if you
have a problem over there bring them
over here to us we can work we have
workers here what is how much of the
challenges that we're reading about is
the shortage of truckers how much of the
challenges we're hearing about is the
shortage of workers how much of the
challenge we're hearing about is
politics
what what is the challenge how much of
the challenge is it the fact that the
ships are not getting someone higher to
get it off what's the real challenge
that's taking place there
the real challenge is a lack of land
space and no one wants to purchase it we
need to get the containers
uh as quick as possible my suggestion is
uh some of it is empties going back some
of these carriers don't want to do it i
suggested to one of the port authorities
that there should be a mandate of 50 of
empty containers that must be
uh loaded back on the vessel to get it
out of here back to wherever we buy our
goods okay
now that that'll clear some of the dock
the the other thing is the third ship
now by the way we have flex flexible
shifts we can work three different start
times on the day shift which is first
shift three different start times on the
second shift which amounts to about 20
hours of work and we do we we have these
staggered shifts
so that's only about a four or five hour
downtime now that four or five hour
downtime uh on the third strip should be
used for consolidating on the dock as
you used to be delivery
uh and they should use the useful rail
movement okay so bnsf has and ups to get
on board also so the stakeholder train
outside the ports has to make a move
it's not the ports you guys are looking
at the seat full of water when the clog
is in the pipe
the clock's in the pipe it's not the
workers it's not it's not anything
there's not any labor shortage with us
we work day and night
and uh the deal is
there's somebody
with this hundred dollar tax i suppose
some of the carriers and some of the uh
everybody else in the stakeholder chain
i don't know i'm not an economist i'm a
longshoremen i'm a fourth gen third
generation 40-year veteran here and all
i know how to do is move cargo and we
move it how do we get more truckers
what's the best what's the best way
what's the best way to increase the
number of truckers in the country some
of the rail railroads have also said
that they're sitting on containers
because there aren't enough truckers to
pick them up from the rail heads so how
do we get more truckers in america
well
uh
that question i can't answer i mean i
i'm just like i said a long instrument
but what i can
i can say is this that
here's here's what's happened to our
economy since we've done overseas trade
every uh consumer your everybody buys uh
amazon i mean i was a crane operator
when i made president in office we have
a very democratic system i was buying
online here's the here's the deal
the container is the warehouse if you go
look at costco you go look at those
shelves you see a pellet that's high up
there and it's got shrink wrap that
wasn't done at any warehouse in america
that was done by whoever
whoever boxed it like say like china
so the container has become the
warehouse
so
what
when when
2019 came around
uh there was a 25
steel tax to china
well
for some odd reason we all of a sudden
got the co bed
in march of 2020
go bigger and where it came from okay
so there was no end game when you
attacked china's economy they attacked
you their way wow i i won't say
conspiracy but you know
uh
uh you know i i read i'm i'm a bible
thumper if you want to call me that
whatever so i have a lot more
thoughts of different than some of my
you and your brothers and sisters but
china does produce 89 of the world's
containers 89 percent is what china
predicts and
how about the percentage of chassis that
they've produced
so america we sold out to everybody
we're buying from everybody it's not
we have to wake up we don't have we
don't have our beaches anymore okay our
economy is outside us
we buy
we ship back to empties and we buy goods
i see it every day ramon two questions
for you
ramon two questions for you number one
are you concerned uh uh uh are you
concerned that some folks are gonna say
you know what i'm just i'm gonna
uh uh instead of the strategy of going
to long beach or l.a i'm gonna go to a
different direction i'm gonna go to
houston i'm gonna go to miami i'm gonna
go to jacksonville i'm gonna go to uh
mexico's port does that thought at all
concern you that someone's not gonna
want to go to la or is this not an l.a
and long beach issue
it's not an alley long beach issue the
supply chain outside of us is cramped
there's kinks everywhere
um
even if they go to another port i'm just
gonna truck it out of there who's gonna
rail it out of there
okay the supply chain outside the boards
i don't care what port it is it's going
to be hit no matter where you take the
connection so you're not at all worried
that it could go elsewhere you're not at
all worried that they're going to go
elsewhere because other places are not
putting that fine of a hundred dollars
and another hundred dollars incremental
day by day if the contenders stay there
well of course i'm always concerned that
work believes us of course that's a
concern
but you know what that's out of my
control and i'm not gonna i don't worry
you know i say my prayers every day the
good lord's been taking care of us hey
we're moving cargo in southern
california
you know
when this balance is out the majority
will be in southern california because
we're going to move it we're going to
move it fast and we're going to push for
rail because rail saves the economy
saves the environment it moves faster
because you don't have a
a congested freeway i can't even get on
i'm going i have to leave so early to
get get to work uh
i live in la mirada and i have to drive
on the 91 and i'm number one lane
everything else is trucks there's no
more room to put trucks anywhere
so when we and the ports are projecting
to get we're we're going to get to what
they call teu is a 20 equivalent unit
we're going to get to where the 20
million mark uh i suppose by this year
we did 10 million in a 12-month period
period in the port of l.a
and uh that was from may to may may 2020
to about may 2021. it was a big
celebration
but uh we're going to continue to move
the cargo faster and more efficient than
anybody
and last last but not least
guarantee that last but not least from
what you know what's what's what are in
these containers you know you're hearing
perishable goods you're hearing how
businesses are telling the you know
america you listen christmas toys are
not going to be delivered on time how
where are you of what are in these
containers
brother
like i said before we purchase
everything outside the u.s
corporations and big business have done
their manufacturing outside the u.s we
don't where are there manufacturing
plants in here where are the toy plants
are they in the u.s where are
where are our automobiles made
detroit's gone
this is just this is this the
the life we live now in america we don't
manufacture in america
wait ramon here
i'm sorry
ramon you and i were talking about this
a little bit last night too and the
phone was kind of breaking up when you
first started talking about it but you
were talking about those companies that
are profiting from
the the owners of the cargo ships do you
think any of this is politically
motivated or anything because of the
profits people are making because of
this shutdown or this slowdown
is there something going on other than
just logistics
um
i i don't know if if you're uh if you're
a carrier and you could make money off
the congestion
and it's working for you
would you even care if the containers
moved or not
i i don't know
the proof's in the pudding carriers the
major three major carriers are recording
3.5 billion a quarter during congestion
they've raised the price of the
container
america you know what are we going to do
uh you tax the carrier he he claims he's
going to go you know they claim they're
going to go elsewhere
okay
well you know what he's going to flinch
first
i don't know man i'm a longshoreman
we've never backed down from anything
we don't leave with our chin either
so you know what if this is the game uh
other countries want to play with us i
know we got to find a strategy to defeat
it and i like i said before longshoremen
are not an economist all i know is i'm
going to be moving cargo as quick and as
fast as we can we're going to work as
many hours as we can now the employers
are the ones who make the orders so when
you when when you look at this us not
working the 24th uh the 24 hours the
employers are the ones that have to put
an order in they order us to go to work
we work your employer says okay you're
working nine to five you're working nine
to five okay whatever it is
so
uh that part of it is what i know well
first of all ramon one thank you for uh
pulling over and being a guest the
audience is definitely uh uh enjoyed
listening to you and number two thank
god a guy like you is leading that eight
thousand and four thousand union as the
president whoever uh gave you the
promotion well deserved to them and well
deserved to you for leading men the way
that you are appreciate the insight and
hopefully in the future when we have
another story like this we'll invite you
back on to come and give us your insight
there's no question about that thanks
buddy appreciate you ramon take care
drive safe
bye bye bye so two things real quick
pull up the market watch story real
quick the one that was up there wow to
his point yesterday it was reported that
our trade deficit rose to a record high
of 96.3 billion exported goods from
america fell four point seven percent
last month okay the record number pull
up the map of the rail network in
america
there
whoa where'd it go
okay
there's not a lot of rail coming out of
southern california to his point look at
where the rail is the rail is the whale
is
is it's where the rust belt used to be
that's where the rail heads were built
and union pacific has invested a hell of
a lot of money in texas and in a rail
head that crosses the border but there's
not a lot of rail traffic coming out of
southern california to his point
what is all of that up there in the
middle illinois ohio what what
those are all small rail lines got it
got it
unbelievable that number you just said
you just kind of went through it fairly
quickly can you go back to that number
she just put up 96
the 9.2 100 almost at 100 billion
dollars a month that's how much we're
importing
uh folks if you're listening to this you
enjoyed what uh ramon had to say and you
want us to bring back guests like this
to kind of give their insight to our you
know foot on the ground give this
channel subscribe uh uh if you enjoy
that uh tom thanks for that uh
introduction with uh ramon that was
amazing that was fascinating i think the
best point he had though too was that
even if you get it off the ships and you
can't get it anywhere then you're stuck
just sitting in the ports and i remember
i worked in a warehouse in norway when
there was a fire in one of the freezers
on the other side of the country they
would literally ship stuff across the
country to us for us to take it out of a
truck repackage it and send it back
because that was more efficient because
of the backlog they were experiencing so
i definitely think that that's something
that i have overseen in terms of they
can get it off the if they can't get it
off the sh get it off the ship and then
it's just stuck at the port it's not
going anywhere and with the backlog we
have there's only room for so much
before they have to start shuffling
things and like you talk to there you're
going four or five in the height and you
have to get a hold of the container at
the bottom you now need to move
four containers just to get that to move
it away and you talk about just
increasing the time of doing that by
four or five creating inefficiencies and
i think the other good point too is
they're busting their ass right they
don't determine their workouts we've not
stopped working right
now yeah that union is hired by the the
companies that bring in the goods and
and need them unloaded and shipped
around so it's not like they're setting
the hours but again what set this off
too much stimulus money to where we went
out and bought stuff like crazy this is
a demand situation all these imports
coming into the country and the trade
deficit being at a record high that's
because we're buying more overseas goods
as a country than we ever have and the
lack of manufacturing he could not be
more clear about the point that we don't
even like detroit has gone as far as
making cars i mean they're out of there
24 percent of components come from china
a lot of the others
prove that we don't have an
infrastructure to support the new
importing as opposed to exporting so if
if that's the way we're gonna keep going
then okay but then we have to adjust the
infrastructure to be able to sustain
that and to be able to get it off where
it needs to be who's going to who's
going to pay for a big old new railroad
that's that's warren buffett he owns one
i like i like how i said i said are you
worried that the business is going to go
elsewhere and and maybe you know to a
different port you know houston you know
miami jacksonville mexico he says of
course it's something i think about but
i don't worry because i'm a praying man
he went to his faith but
he said of course i do that that does
concern me because there's a reason that
the president of panama was recently in
the city of houston having a big old
celebration because the the the the
units that are coming into the houston
port because of the widening of the
panama canal are at record levels
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]